hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to west of loathing now I
know some of you may not have heard of
this game but it's made by the same
developers of kingdom of loathing and
I've been looking forward to it since
PAX East in Boston what I saw in that
game was that it was hilarious and I
don't know if it's gonna be hilarious
the whole way through I don't want to
overhype it but everything I saw in the
Oh everything I saw in there really
hilarious right who do we want to be
Earl Dalton Edwin Jones
Jorn Walker edit your name name oh I can
edit my name now my name is mumbler fum
fum per this is the adventure of mum
Fleur bumper dink in West of loathing
alright there we go
whoa I had the strangest dream I was
choosing a character class should I
become a bean slinger Oh or a snake
oiler oh my god
did they somehow make my gun into a
flamethrower and oh my god snake oiler
oh that's so funny well I want to be a
cowpuncher
alright I'll be a cowpuncher cowpunchers
solve their problems with their fists
whether it's shaking them and a
disagreeable feller in a disreputable
saloon or using them to punch a slightly
more disagreeable feller in a slightly
less reputable saloon you've heard the
cow punches are in demand out west since
the cows came home which stands to
reason the cows aren't gonna wait let me
read of what the bean slinger is magic
and cooking are inextricably intertwined
and loathing and the bean slinger is a
mystical master of both you've heard
there's a shortage of cooks out west
since the cows came home due to most of
the cooks having been brutally killed by
the cows maybe not
snake lawyers rely on their moxie and
hooks to tame snakes they're fearless
its to extract potent oils from those
snakes and their cleverness to
manufacture and sell potions made from
those oils you've heard snake Oilers are
doing really well out west since the
cows came home
everybody needs potions and hope in
these dark days and also out west is
where all the best snakes lived that's
alright but I think I'm gonna go with
cowpuncher those cows ain't no punch oh
man I'm so excited for this game all
right what do we got this weird poster
appeared here one night all right I can
jump for joy at that fact I can't do
anything else about it read the spine of
one of your books
Chester danger in the mystery of the
forbidden lighthouse that was one of my
favorites
herb Brown and the curse of the ancient
cellar dad gave me this one when I was
kid the occurrence at rattlesnake
mansion Rufus like this one as much as I
did B bay Brown in the curse of the
black bridge Jefferson Swift in the old
Gulch
the miracle at the black Hospital oh hey
this one might come in handy I got
walking stupid well that's what I like
to do I like to walk stupid unlock
stupid tale of a renegade sheriff who
was really really bad at walking you
read the book from cover to cover and
learn how to walk stupid stupid walking
has been added to your optionmenu you
got a perk stupid walking you
accidentally dropped the book and then
ruin it by step oh well at least i
unlock stupid walking how do I do that
oh no do I just do that always now when
you're a child you wanted to walk so
badly you finally you doing missie buddy
caw-caw feed Russell a cricket you grab
a cricket from your cricket bag and feed
it to Russell he coos appreciatively and
noses your hand maybe it's time for you
to leave too you open your bedroom
window not pictured and unlatch the door
to Russell's cage he winced at you cause
one last time then flies away to the
west it's time to hit the trail oh maybe
I'll see you Russell out on the trail
goodbye desk comb hair comb your hair
one last time I can't xb
great I don't seem
[Laughter]
goodbye bad time to add West and chase
my real dreams goodbye phonograph oh you
pull the needle away from the cylinder
and stow the handle away I think I've
done all these so there's no more there
okay anyway let's crab walk out of here
nothing on the Hatrack today what a mess
oh look at me I'm so organized
alright sir that really puts the hearth
and hearth and home alright alright see
you're gonna miss mom's cooking I sure
AM oh my god it's mom's pie save it
keeps all our pie safe oh you'll miss
meals with the family Oh your little
brothers room you pick up one of your
brothers weird books and flip through it
over mathematic he'd Everest galore
redo the play it just gives me a
headache you picking one of your
brothers weird books and flip through it
on the application and dynamics of a
general mathematical method previous
applied to optics I think this is about
math maybe you pick up one of your
butters and an endless investigation of
the laws of a thought on which are
founded the mathematical theories of
logic and probabilities just a title
give me a take you looking let's see
I got a puzzle cube alright I stole his
puzzle cube third wheel alright nothing
here it's covered with all weird
diagrams and charts alright well God all
right I think it's time to go I think
it's time to get out of here oh ma ma ma
ma are you proud of me ma ma see no time
to screw around I'm dead West deleted
I'm um
don't mind me crab walking towards my
mother alright your mom smiles warmly as
you approach I'm leaving now mom we're
gonna miss you kiddo
oh and before you leave I got you a
present Oh a present yep it's a book you
wanted for Crimbo I know it's early but
what's
Rimbaud oh the one about bartering oh
boy but one about desert survival oh boy
the one about picking locks oh boy I
always do pick the picking locks route
whenever I have options like this that's
the one enjoy it
locks and how to pick them please be
careful out there right it's a lever
when you can oh thanks mom excuse me dad
are you doing your father morosely jabs
at the haystack that had to thank you
dad that doesn't fit you I'll grow into
it okay all right goodbye time to remiel
leave his lip Quivers a little listen I
want you to have this it's your grandpa
thank you good good luck out there be
sure to say goodbye to your mother I did
goodbye dad I did it I got a needle dad
you proud of me or anything else in
there
prove your brother roofers are standing
there looking nervous he's pretty good
at looking nervous give him his puzzle
back you hand him his puzzle and he
starts fidgeting with it say goodbye hey
roof it's time for me to head west I
still don't understand why you're
leaving he's got a point you know why
are you going west I'm gonna help people
you've read the papers Rufus the people
out west are in trouble they need all
the help they can get but it's so
dangerous sixty percent of the people
who go west get killed within a year and
that statistics from before the cows
came home I'll be okay don't worry you
worry about taking care of mom and dad
I'll worry about me okay if you say so I
think I still think you'll DB dead by
Crimbo is Crimbo Christmas what Crimbo
is Oh Missy Rufus okay you give him a
playful punch in the arm
too bad I'm a cowpuncher and it
devastated him shot him across the
entire cityscape oh man I've got new
options Oh nerd mode combat grid what is
this stupid oh I can turn them off why
would I want to turn off my stupid
walking save inventory Oh best font
changes typeface to game Arial please
don't do this
ah that don't look good that don't look
good at all Alex
good I guess Nass that's good nerd mode
I'll turn on nerd mode sure I got those
I don't know what those do let's see all
right I got brass knuckles good for
cow-punching
character mum plumper dink on the fun /
dink farm is this the thumper ding farm
all right you guys I'm out of here scuse
me go west young man yeah but let me see
if I can talk to my parents again he's
just barely holding it together it's
probably best if you just go your mom
raises an eyebrow I just wanted one more
hug before I leave she smiles and hugs
you again one more hug please when are
you gonna get tired of giving me hugs
mom all right let's go ooh hitching a
ride across the Great Plains what am I
sitting on carrots beets I don't want to
skip the opening credits this is the
good stuff
Zach Johnson you did great here Victor
Thompson Kevin Simmons good job on all
this I don't know why there's a film
editor but that doesn't make a lot of
sense dialect okay what am i doing to
those dead impaired stunt coordinator
again seems a little odd a key grip
Chris Moyer hmm sure about these opening
credits boom up or 200 miles later only
200 miles well that's not very far to go
west maybe I'm not there yet
oh no I'm there dirt water Oh No don't
fall off oh no you're dead now well you
stupid walks go well the bad news is you
fell off the cart and got knocked out
for a couple hours and now you got no
ride no meeting no prospects the good
news is that you're in a town rather
than in a Gulch somewhere not much of a
town though get yourself up and dry
yourself off hey I like this town hey
buddy you doing can I pick up this
turnip god dust be Furnham hey watch it
hick buddy no hey does this look like a
hick to you a sign on the door reads
gone drinking you gone drinking can't a
fella Buffalo gals won't you
tonight what are you talking about
Buffalo gals oh [ __ ] I just stepped in
free Oh goddamnit
Wow you skated right into that food all
right what's in here as you walk in the
saloon the krazee-eyez guys sitting to
the left of the door shrieks and waves
at you to get your attention
hey where's your hot dagnabbit well I
you can't drink in here without a hat
tape proper he points to the take a hat
leave a hat box next to the door check
out the box you look through the hat box
and find a sturdy looking Stetson that
looks like something you'd wear oh I got
a four gallon hat you grab the hat and
put it on thanks Pete thanks Pete he
gives you a friendly if somewhat twitchy
nod say feller yeah you headin west if
and you want some company I'd be more
than happy to come along just lemon oh
well no pressure all right keep that in
mind where am I Oh what'd you say Pete
who me well I say all kinds of things
for instance dag damn machines can't
trust no more than a double-crossing
so-and-so uh-huh
Pete takes a swig of his whiskey see you
later Pete why can't I read that so well
it's a spittoon people spit in it you
know without without even looking in it
that's absolutely disgusting
i'ma look in it yeah let's spit regular
spit gross tobacco spit chewin gum in it
looks like a few teeth as well it's
disgusting and it's metal even from a
distance it smells whole it smells
horrible
look closer you are now on your hands
and knees peering into a filth encrusted
spittoon I don't know what is wrong with
you wait is there something shining at
the bottom get it you reach your hand
towards the spittoon even before you
touch it you could feel the grossest in
the air like a greasy fog enveloped
stinking rats or it smells like vomit
trough at a mesquite barbecue eating
contest you hesitate never surrender you
blend your hand into the awful soup it
makes a sound like gloves
because that was something you pull your
hand out of the devil's terrine slowly
not daring to risk splashing the
contents all over yourself you fear to
have gotten some kind of disease as well
congratulations you got an item nasty
ring though getting this ring was
traumatic you have to admit that it was
worth it
I got muscle mocks moxie and mystic
ality oh it's so funny so much okay
alright anyway ooh I should read this ah
there we go quickly memorize the entire
book after you're done reading it you
donate to the local orphanage soon those
orphans will be able to make okay these
guys are playing poker
Early's trying to they keep looking back
and forth from their hand on how to play
poker card but the game came with biting
their lips and concentrating real hard
good luck guys alright you walk up into
the bar and wait patiently for the
bartender to notice you while you're
waiting you see a sign taped to the back
wall reading reward for lost mugs 25
each
the bartender finally notices how to
cowboy howdy barkeep my name's Mumford
what brings you to our little backwater
oh the usual all came out west to make
my fortune not having much luck so far
though any work around these parts
unfortunately boring Springs already has
more people in it than jobs
it's more of an errand town if you catch
my meeting if you're looking for a real
job I'd recommend taking the railroad
people up by dirt water okay the
railroad the manifest destiny railroad
company from back east they're trying to
run a line to Frisco and having a heck
of a time doing it and they're hiring oh
I reckon they're always hiring for one
thing or another big company dirt water
water is interesting it's owned a far
enough West there's still more or less
exempt from the rule law but not so far
West has been burned to the ground by
the dam cows lots of opportunity there
he pauses first few seconds lost in
thought yep if I were a younger man I'd
probably head that way myself
all right you mentioned Aaron yes
forsaken burg has always fall apart in
one way or another the hostlers always
needing help since he hurt his leg and
that no account sure feint could
certainly stand to have somebody doing
his job for him anything else well I've
got a goblin loose in the basement some
cowpoke's in from goats didn't wipe his
boots off and got spores everywhere
right handle of Goblin much obliged a
little off basement door for you oh and
you'll need this weak fungicide I'll
take care of it I don't know what kind
of world we live in where goblins are
the norm but I'm understand never I'm
talking to you now how do you I'm mum
Fleur
howdy mom Fleur I'm Horace nice to meet
you what do you do on the town Hossler I
don't know what that is I'm the town
horse self yeah gotcha how's that
working out for you oh these horses are
just flying out the door so business is
booming nice no I mean the horses keep
running away I haven't sold one in ages
oh is that why you're here drinking
instead hey yep and me being in here
drinking instead of watching those
horses is probably how they keep
escaping it's one of those vicious
circle things well I'm in need of a
horse do you have any left one kind of
boring once got four legs and a back to
sit on come see me at the stable I'll be
able to show do you are okay by then all
right
the woman glares at you you should
probably just let her drink excuse me uh
never mind
who's the lady drinking whiskey out of a
beer mug let's see
that's Suzy she's arranged for from
nearby real tough broad I ain't
recommend you pester her why's that
lost her family went a kook our tack
recently got some pent up frustrations
about it
ouch well I happen to be a professional
cowboy sure let's see
howdy Suzy howdy cowboy who's gonna be
searching the spittoon for his teeth if
he don't leave me in peace okay well bye
then excuse me you already have a hat
what would you do with two I don't know
have a choice in my life it's probably
even blown yeah but I probably won't I'm
a screw my butt towards alright never
mind I'm going to the basement oh is
that a goblin excuse me I'm as weird as
you write a bottle of old newspapers you
got boring Springs Gazette
whiskey creative nurse brand whiskey
good for what ails you
grab
bottle and I'm gonna tumble tell me I'm
a double weed let's see gobbling shouts
Bree York
alright let's fight Oh
fight fight fight we gotta jump um wait
don't I have a fungicide time to do that
this would be the 25 damage to target
assuming it's a goblin or I'm gonna
spray you take oh well that seems
horrible the goblins fungal flesh
disintegrates oh I got muscle level too
I don't know what that means but okay
it's dead now I guess that's good for me
gonna go upstairs now
hey bar Keith took care of that goblin
problem for you took care of it
thank you kindly I knew you was a
stand-up feller the moment you walked in
here he reached his under the bar and
grabs a bag of meat is the currency meat
here you go it's the least I can do by
way of thanks just thought I'd say howdy
alright goodbye then see
howdy Susie okay goodbye or I'm gonna go
out then just crawl through this [ __ ]
sheriff hey Sheriff howdy stranger
welcome to boring Springs on the surf in
these parts the what the sheriff okay
blasted sound painters say you wouldn't
happen to be looking for work
would you depends on the work well how
does this grab you
there's gang hoodlums running around
here they call themselves the fricker
gang last time arrested one of them they
busted the mountain took my cell door
Wilma
it ain't uh well ain't much good without
door and I need somebody tough smart and
or slick to go fetch you back for me see
why don't you do it you're the sheriff I
gotta stay here and practice my chair
tipping all right sure funny did she say
that
cuz I'm sending the deputy along with
you to keep you out of trouble
oh the deputy's a gardener you're new in
town maybe you ain't noticed but there
ain't much to do here sip drink here let
me write you down with a fricker gang
howdy is far yeah he makes a little note
on your map you discover the new map
location the Fricker gangs hideout got
it I'll be back with the door maybe
wanted four birds left naked Mike
Bernstein
are we all naked or is it just without a
hat is the Hat the determination of
what's naked help wanted poster artists
apply in person at the human Marshals
office wanted Demi frikar for face
plotted 420 meet blazes
well alright then gonna go Oh beer mug
wait okay I can turn that in that's
right I can turn that in for monetary
rewards yeah I got a beer mug
much obliged alright Ben just thought
I'd say goodbye
alright so I got a fresh well just
cartwheeled into that [ __ ] again but I
gotta go trade step right up step right
up
braids the name and trades the game you
seriously doubt that his name is braid
howdy braid what are you trading well
sir today I'm trading locks for soap and
a stick of dynamite for a needle and if
accountant Skinner who brings me through
rattlesnake hides well to that
adventurous so I will trade a fine
silver pocket watch
I don't know if I need required sticker
n' how about some free dynamite requires
dickering
I want the dickering skill I'd probably
have that if I sold snake oil then I
wouldn't be able to can't punch cow so
good oh hi weird cactus man ibrid he
smiles at you howdy cactus man howdy
yourself and the name's bill cactus bill
what happened to you bill well to be
honest partner I drank too much cactus
beer and turned me into a cactus
Knockouts warned me this would happen
but I didn't listen
and that's why they call you cactus bill
no that's just a coincidence Oh does it
hurt does what hurt you know being a
cactus huh no it's actually an it kind
of nice the natural fermentation process
inside the cactus part of me keeps me
pretty drunk most of the time I guess
it's am i boring yeah I bet it wouldn't
be so bad if I had something to read you
don't happen to have a newspaper or
anything would you oh I got a newspaper
what splice partner now let's see here
what can I do in the return the favor
oh I know my trouble I left it behind
the outhouse it or hold mine it's yours
if you go get it I'm sure you'll find it
useful
behind the outhouse and over whole mine
got it thanks Bill don't mention it now
if you could just kind of stick that
newspaper to my face before
oh there we go
that's nice some loose dirt I need to
get the shovel for the loose dirt I get
it I understand all right so this
whiskey is too cheap for you to even
consider drinking it and giving your
legendarily low standards that's really
saying something all right so I got a I
got find ah the Freaker gang hideout oh
well this guy's sleeping
thud Fricker the fricker gangs intrepid
lookout appears to be taking a nap just
shoot him Lana ignore him for now cuz
he's sleeping why would I need to shoot
him shut up
your barrel castle requires force Jim
pile of random stuff finders keepers I
got a mug I got cufflinks oh did I quit
those cufflinks no I did not okay got
cufflinks you wore fancier shirts you
might have some use for these well I
don't so you know that is what it is
perk stupid
oh so good all right let's carry on
sneak in here all sneaky-like yeah ain't
never gonna find their they seem to all
be sleeping oh this guy one of the
fricken boys is dozing just keep a soap
thank you alright alright so what's up
with them
you cautiously approached the Fricker
gang they're pretty engrossed in that
poker game so it doesn't actually
require that much caution you hide
behind a barrel and eavesdrop on the
conversation for a while the one with
the eye patch is quiet but you gather
that his name is snipe and that the
squirrelly one is his brother wimpy
what's your play there talk howdy boys
deal me in the one without the eyepatch
raises an eyebrow yeah who are you how'd
you get past sudden soapy what do you
want
it's bimmy it's me me it's me be me your
brother he's Quincey you bimmy you ain't
Binney
Lizzy I said I am so Benny I stole some
rubes face
it's what's new baby we got to get out
of here and fast
wimpy the Pinkertons are on to us and
they'll be here any minute dagnabbit
come on snipe let's hightail it I'll
catch up with you guys later would be
nods music you congratulate yourself on
your attentiveness memory and strong
interpersonal skills
I got grit level two is that the real
grit let's grab the door and or put that
in my pocket but okay well Byam slits
liven pile of ill-gotten gains all right
20 me
oh this congrates I love this tie him up
if I tie him up won't he die what the
freakin boys if I tie him up in a
bathtub he's gonna drown right be
horrible I mean I don't know if I want
to kill these people yet but they're
probably bad what if I wake him up you
poke thud hey you're not supposed to be
here that is well let's say he's no
Rhodes Scholar if we assume that it's
seven years from now and that idiom
makes sense you kind of feel bad at the
idea of kid in killing him walk away
food you don't want this Oh take I okay
you're probably right thud stumbles off
into the desert
he'll probably fine I got an honorable
perk I don't know what that means what
does that mean I'm an honorable ahh you
got strong moral compass and an accurate
methyl protractor talk about you're
talking about there no honorable options
will be available in some situations oh
that's nice
so maybe I should do something with this
guy won't eat I I'm a time up grab a
nearby length of rope and carefully ties
hands together and then the handles to
the handles of the tub the sheriff can
come collect and letter let sleeping
bandits line okay well all right then
well we got that so there we go got
handstand out of here because I'm still
victorious all right I guess we got to
go back now doodlee do we do lead ooh
gonna go get some money from the sheriff
maybe I don't know if he's gonna give me
money for this hey sure I got it
I see the fricker gang hasn't put a stop
to your breathing did you rescue my cell
door
janna sure if his door and he hangs our
backup on the hinges nice work stranger
they see your prison cell just got about
four times more secure
are there any freaking boys left for me
to round up and one or two that are
asleep on the job
oh I guess I should have left the other
one to sleep oh you got honorable I'll
go around them up shortly then looks
like I owe you a rule no there's a
little task for you if you got time
should be a lot simpler than the last
what you need well the Fricker's busted
the lock when they took the door gonna
need a new lock keep an eye out la dee
da dee da keep an eye out hey I got some
soap now bright I got I'll trade soap
for a lot well I got lock now guess
that's as easy as it comes all righty
then final I'll do that cool I got a
lock
hey buddy that one right here that'll do
nicely
I sure puts the lock on the door and
accidentally drops the key in clatters
into the cell hell fire don't suppose
you gotta know how to pick a lock
stranger you got a needle handy oh I do
oh I do oh it consumes an out whatever
I'm gonna probably have to blow it up if
I didn't all right you unlock the cell
door better let the chef reclaim his G I
locked it for you sure if walks and
picks a key looks around place to hide
in the vindaloo sticks it unders hat
thank you kindly stranger that bar and
springs ever gets any more criminals
they better watch out that's a good job
you done now
imagine it here have a sip souvenir of
your time and Boren Springs I got a sure
bet I'll probably come in handy maybe no
else did you need for a trade howdy
I need Darin I need the dicker and skill
but I don't know how to get that either
way I got a shirt badge oh oh it gives
me armor he usually gives them to
children hooter the Gail perfect oh this
item goes on your lapel do I even have a
lapel not hundred percent sure either
way let me return these I bought it I
got these mugs Thanks all right besides
daddy dad you still nicer how did you
see all right bye then
so anyway I think that's all the time I
got for the first episode of wet west of
loathing but this is oh I got a broken
board from ow
Frick dang it dang dude er ow okay so
anyway I got I got what I need there and
so I think that's enough time but this
game I love this game so much already
well I'm in love with this game it's so
fun it's so fun so I'll put a link to
this game in the description below if
you guys want to play for yourself and
I'm gonna do a full playthrough of this
there's no way I'm not gonna do a full
playthrough of this but let me know what
you think down the comments below
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]